i feel very betrayed by my country
i also feel betrayed by the eu
negotiators
[Music]
a lot of britons live in europe we don't
hear about them that much and they don't
get much political representation in the
uk or in europe
but they exist and they've had to make
some pretty tough choices as a result of
brexit the numbers remain 48
leave 52
i was absolutely amazed by the
the way i felt when i saw the result
i broke into tears immediately and i was
angry i was depressed i was in disbelief
my husband is french he's a french
engineer
my plan was that
i would be here with him
while he worked and then when we retired
i was planning on moving back to england
the trouble is that his french
and the settled status
would probably be refused
but i would have liked to have been able
to move home
and i can't do that anymore and it hurts
we never thought that there would be any
political success in getting anyone in
britain to reconsider the decision
that's how it was but i think we were
hoping for a softer brexit so yeah it
was stressful and we talked to friends
who were in similar positions with what
have been kind of part-time homes who
thought what we're gonna do a lot of
people have had to secure their rights
in europe and that means getting a
residency card or seeking citizenship
and there are a lot of administrative
fees related to that
without brexit life would have been an
awful lot easier for a lot of people a
lot of the documentation is not for the
faint-hearted but you're in the system
you have to understand it and you've got
to get help the french can be quite
strict about these things and they will
find you heavily if you make mistakes i
think in many ways we've probably
benefited from a greater understanding
of how the country works because we're
now part of it and it sends out certain
signals i think to french neighbors as
well
[Music]
another issue that people have been
facing is a drop in the value of a pound
compared to the euro it's affected me
financially certainly
i'm a british state pensioner so any
difference in the exchange rate is going
to impact my income i'm also finding it
now very expensive to travel and much
more complicated
i do have an elderly mother in the uk
who i you know like to visit as often as
i can but i'm having to limit my trips
in terms of number for a year and how
long i stay for even bringing stuff back
and forth between the two
areas between the two zones has become
so complicated that
a lot of people just don't go back to uk
as much as they used to you think well
anything over a couple of hundred quid
you know
you might fall foul of things that
before brexit you wouldn't have done i
am rather fond of cheddar
much as i like spanish cheeses and i
like to think i'm integrated there are
certain things that
you like from home and up to brexit you
know i always used to bring some home in
my suitcase besides finances i think a
lot of britain's in europe are dealing
with
a form of identity crisis
even though i'm very very british at
heart emotionally i am a european
citizen
now european citizenship to me is closer
to a religion than it is
an administrative status
i hope that justice will be served and
that we'll manage to get back what we've
lost i'm not proud of the country
anymore um in fact it shames me that
some of the things that are going on i
won't be happy until i've got all my eu
rights back and there's only two ways to
do that either brexit is cancelled or i
become a spanish citizen i'm not quite
sure why i'm still clinging on to my
britishness other than i've been british
all my life
and you know that's that's hard to throw
away